this is a production of Cornell
University I'm glad to see everyone here
for the mixtures session so my name is
Charlie white I'm a research associate
at Penn State and I feel very lucky to
be representing a big team of
researchers and extension educators and
Farmar collaborators and organization
organizations that work with us to share
some results from our cover crop
mixtures research experiment that we've
been doing it at Penn State and on
collaborating farms so if any of you
have traveled around the countryside
this time of year you've probably seen
tents like this cropping up in in cover
crop fields around around your areas and
if you were to wander inside one of
those tents you might find a cover crop
evangelist like this preaching about the
benefits of cover crop mixtures this is
Ray Archuleta how many of you've seen
presentations by Ray Archuleta okay so
there's a lot of benefits potential
benefits that cover crop mixtures can
provide and we're hearing a lot about
those out in the farming community and
and on the extension circuit and there's
some good information good background
information that has led to this belief
in the benefit of cover crop mixtures so
there's a long-standing hypothesis the
biodiversity ecosystem function
hypothesis that says you know as we
increase diversity in a field were
increasing the services and the
functionality that can be provided and
these functions could be plant biomass
production they could be weed
suppression beneficial insects nitrogen
retention nitrogen supply and so on and
so forth so our team our very large team
wanted to address this specifically
related to cover crop mixtures can we
increase the functionality and service
provisioning of mixtures in a cover
cropping system so like I said there's a
very large team and everyone on this
team has contributed to the work that
I'll be presenting this afternoon and
it's been funded through two projects
funded by the OREA
Ram okay so the main experiment is at
the Rock Springs Research Station we're
using at least the phase of the
experiment that I'm going to describe
today the first three years we use these
six species in the experiment so we have
two legumes red clover and Austrian
winter pea we have two brassicas canola
and forage radish two grasses cereal rye
and oats and these plant families are
also crossed with winter hardiness
classes so all of these species up here
on the top these are all reliably winter
hardy species in our climate of central
Pennsylvania and these species on the
bottom these are all winter killed
mostly winter killed Austin winter pea
it kind of depends when you plant it but
more often than not in our climate it's
been winter killing so we have we have
these six different species that
represent different plant families
different growth patterns in time and we
used we planted those six species and
monocultures as control comparisons and
then we also created four mixtures out
of those six species and the mixtures we
assembled to target different functional
functional goals and also to have a
gradient of species diversity so we have
the three species n treatment which has
clover P and rye and this is a focused
on nitrogen management so the rise in
their to scavenge nitrogen in the winter
these are all planted after winter wheat
and going into corn so we also want a
supply nitrogen to the corn crops so
we've got the clover and the pea in
there the three species W that's for
weed management this is in an organic
cropping system experiment so we're not
using any herbicides so we're looking
for the cover crop to provide some weed
suppression services so we have oat in
there as a fast growing species and then
rye is a high biomass species in the
spring and because we're going into corn
we wanted to have some nitrogen as well
so we have the clover in there for
species mix so we're starting to
increase in species diversity we have a
clove
p and rise so those are the same three
species that we have up here but now
we're adding canola as well and canola
being abrasca has some interesting
tissue chemistry it's also a species
that will flower or relatively early in
the spring so we're getting from
flowering the canola is flowering before
terminating it and the idea is that we
can attract some beneficial insects or
provide a habitat and resources for
native bee populations with the canola
and then we've got our six species mix
here which is kind of the high diversity
mix for our experiment and we're just
looking to maximize diversity and
hopefully if our theory is right
maximize the services and benefits that
we get from the mixture okay so we're
looking at multi functionality of these
cover crops that we've measured lots of
different services that they're
providing and I'll just go around here
so biomass production above-ground
biomass we harvested in the fall and the
spring nitrogen retention this is an
anion exchange resin bag we buried this
at 25 centimeters when we plant the
cover crop in the fall and then we dig
that up in the spring and we can extract
the nitrate that leach through the soil
profile through this bag there and scale
that up to an aerial basis we're
measuring nitrogen supply and here we
actually use a biogeochemical model to
predict the nitrogen availability based
on the c2n ratio and the total end
content of the cover crop biomass we're
measuring cash crop production so this
is going into corn silage profitability
which is essentially the change in
silage yields from a cover crop
treatment compared to the fallow control
minus the cost of the cover crop seed so
it's a partial it's a partial budgeting
technique of looking at the
profitability effect we're looking at
pest suppression so this is actually a
meadow rhythm which is a soil soil
fungus intimate pathogenic fungus that
can infect the larvae of different pests
pest organisms looking at weed
suppression so we measured above-ground
weed biomass in the cover
up stand in the fall and in the spring
and we're looking at changes in the soil
carbon and the data we're using in this
analysis is the act of carbon so this is
the potassium permanganate extractable
carbon it's a fraction of the soil
carbon that changes more rapidly when
you have a management induced change so
these are all the services that we
measured and since we're looking at
multi-functionality what we actually did
is we averaged standardized values for
all of these services we averaged them
together into what we're calling a multi
functionality index so this figure shows
you that multi-functionality index
across the cover crop species richness
and we have average values for each of
the treatments here but the main thing
main pattern I want to show you here is
that there's not a great relationship
between our cover crop species richness
so the number of species of cover crops
that we have and the average
multi-functionality
right r-squared of 0.03 that's very low
you know just you know the average of
the mixtures was actually a little bit
better than the average of the
monocultures
but you see quite a spread in the
monocultures actually the pea
monoculture was more multifunctional on
average than many of the mixes were so
just cover crop species richness number
of species alone was a very poor
predictor of this multi-functionality so
we wanted to look at other aspects of
diversity right so species richness
isn't the only component of diversity
that might have an effect on multi
functionality and the direction that we
went in was to look at functional
diversity and we found that there's a
metric of functional diversity called
relative raus quadratic entropy that as
we increased in that functional
diversity metric our average
multi-functionality increased so that's
good that was that actually kind of fits
the hypothesis of increasing diversity
increases multi-functionality it just
didn't
to be species species diversity it's
it's functional diversity so we also
wanted to know why what was driving this
increase was it an increase in the
positive benefits that cover crops
provide or was it a decrease in some of
the drawbacks so for example nitrogen
immobilization or reducing cash crop
yields
those can be drawbacks that those
negative aspects are actually averaged
into this mean value here so if we
decompose these averaged values into the
the positive services which are these
black triangles and the negative dis
services which are the squares here what
we saw is that the services actually
didn't change so the benefits that we're
getting from cover crops the positive
benefits are staying the same as we
increase diversity but the drawbacks
that cover crops can sometimes cause
like nitrogen immobilization or
something like that those drawbacks are
actually getting getting better we're
ameliorating the dis services that cover
crops can sometimes provide so this was
an interesting finding that diversity
had this effect on ameliorating that dis
services so I think there's some some
potential benefits to cover crop
mixtures but there's also some
challenges so challenge number one
understanding functional diversity right
you can't call up your C company and say
hey give me the your seed mix with the
highest relative rouse quadratic entropy
right
they'll probably hang up the phone and
think you dialed the wrong number is
there anyone in this room they can even
tell me what Rao's relative browsed
quadratic entropy is anyone come on be
brave if you know okay so there's a lot
that we need to do to enhance our
literacy of functional diversity if this
is if this is what's going to be driving
improvements in cover crop mixtures we
need to understand what functional
diversity is and how to manage that so I
want to give you a quick little primer
here so functional diversity is all
about the functional traits that the
plant species have and these traits
things like the fall growth rate the
spring growth rate the carbon and
nitrogen ratio these
traits are what drive the provisioning
of these services and you can take these
traits when you start thinking about
functional diversity you have to take
these traits and then you have to plot
them in a multi-dimensional space okay
so this is luckily here we only have
three traits that we used in our
analysis so we can you know visualize it
in three dimensions but you can add as
many traits as you want here and
mathematically it kind of takes care of
this multi-dimensional space but it's
you know it's nice to visualize it in
three dimensions so these are actually
our six species with their different
trait values plotted in and
multi-dimensional trait space here so
then you can take the the six species
and you can start connecting them so
these are all our mixtures here so the
three species and the P the RAI the red
clover
if you connect these together you get
essentially a volume of space and you
can look at the the center of the trait
space so this is this black dot here
that's the centroid you can look at the
distance that things are from the
centroid and you can look at how evenly
the biomass is between all of the
species and so those aspects evenness
richness which is the the volume of the
space divergence which is how far apart
things are on average from the center
these are components of functional
diversity and we ran a number of
different functional diversity metrics
that account for one or more of these
things you can combine these in
different metrics to account for all
three of them or just one or two of the
three and relative rao's quadratic
entropy was the one that was predictive
of our multi functionality and this
indicator takes into account evenness in
divergence so what this is telling us is
what you want is you want to have
species that are well spaced out from
each other and you want to have even
biomass across all of the species in
your mixture so this is actually if all
of this
biomass was even this would be a fairly
divergent mixture when we go to the four
species mix actually adding this canola
in the middle here that reduces our
divergence okay because we've put a
species in there that has traits that
are very close to the middle and we want
traits that are evenly spaced across the
edge so this is actually a case where
adding a fourth species if you're
thinking about species diversity is as
your indicator adding the fourth species
actually reduced our functional
diversity here so I think there's some
traps that we could fall into when we
don't understand functional diversity
you might think oh let me add four or
five six species well here's another
good example of where having some
species in the middle of this volume
reduces the divergence so I think
increasing our literacy around
functional diversity will help us create
better mixtures but higher performing
mixtures
okay so challenge number two you now
have to have evenness spread out around
the edges of your trait space which
means you need to manage cover crop
mixtures to be even in their biomass
production and this is a figure that
shows biomass or essentially the
composition of the cover crop stand over
time for the four different mixtures
here so we have the composition at
seeding so this is plants per meter
squared we have the composition at
germination so the number of plants that
germinated per meter squared our fall
biomass composition and our spring
biomass composition for the the
different mixtures and each of these
shaded areas different colors represents
a different species in the mix and what
we saw is that across all of the
mixtures is in spring we had a strong
convergence towards cereal rice cereal
rye really dominated a lot of our mixes
we lost red clover was really a minor
component you know so we really didn't
achieve very even mixtures in in this
first stage of the experiment this is a
picture of the three species nitrogen
here in spring the first year of the
experiment so the cereal rye you see
very tall here red clover is you know
just hanging on down there a little bit
of Austrian winter pea so that was it
that was a big challenge for evenness
and we knew in the second phase of this
experiment we needed to do something
about the evenness so we switched up our
species that we used in these mixes and
in in the the second phase of the
experiment we shifted RIE to triticale
and we shifted red clover to crimson
clover so if you know anything about rye
and red clover rye is the fastest
growing of the grasses in the spring red
clover is the slowest growing of the
legumes in the spring and so we set this
we basically set this mixture up for
failure because of the differences in
spring growth rates so now we're going
to a slower growing grass the triticale
and a faster growing clover the crimson
clover and we're seeing much more even
biomass in the stands another challenge
for evenness is that the expression of
these mixtures is very different across
different farm sites because of the soil
fertility and the climate at each site
so this is the four species mixture
planted four different locations these
three were on farm locations and so this
shows the the biomass composition in the
fall and you see depending on these
different sites like this site was
almost all canola this was all kunal
most all canola but a good bit of pea
here we had canola and rye here it was
mostly rye a little bit of canola and
pea
so the factors that we think are driving
this are the temperate the climate and
the nitrogen status so in the second
phase of our work we've really focused
on looking at gradients of climate and
nitrogen status at seeding to be able to
predict how the biomass might shift and
try and adjust our seeding rates so a
postdoc on the project Barbara barabar
has a poster this evening looking at
some of this work where we're
mechanistically changing planting dates
and nitrogen fertility
looking at differences in biomass
composition so we'd welcome you to stop
by that okay when we think another
challenge when we think about you know
doing a spider plot like this the just
that the layout of this spider plot
implicitly implies that these services
are somewhat independent of each other
and that it might actually be possible
to have you know high service levels on
all of these around you know if you
theoretically have the optimal mixture
what we saw from the data in the first
phase of this experiment this is a
principal components analysis with all
of our services and this type of
analysis what it does is it allows you
to see what services are associated with
each other which services are opposed
with each other which services are
independent of each other and so the way
things shook out is we have these
bundles of services so nitrogen supply
cash crop production and profitability
were all related to each other so this
is a service bundle here and a different
bundle of services were actually opposed
so there was a trade-off so nitrogen
retention weed suppression and biomass
production these were somewhat clustered
together these are all opposed to each
other so there's a trade-off between
these services soil carbon and pest
suppression seem to be relatively
independent so how do we how do we
manage this trade-off well in all of the
data that we have from on-farm
experiments and research station
experiments we were able to with the
nitrogen trade-off at least start to
understand what's driving this trade-off
so we have cover crop management factors
that are affecting nitrogen supply and
nitrogen retention and there's also soil
management factors and for the cover
crop management factors increasing the
non legumes seeding rate more having
more grasses more brassicas that
increase our nitrogen retention that
makes sense they're good scavengers for
our nitrogen supply keeping a low
biomass c2n ratio in spring and fall
that increase our nitrogen supplies so
increasing these the
Crees nitrogen supply having more
nitrogen in the biomass in the spring
increased nitrogen supply and the
trade-off between these two services is
actually this indirect effect we're
increasing the non legging seeding rate
increased the c2n ratio which decreased
the nitrogen supply so the if we look at
our soil management factors here we see
that increasing the fall soil nitrogen
so farms that applied manure in the fall
had a high nitrate level in the fall
they had a highly Qing load when we had
that high level of nitrate in the soil
we needed more of a non legume seeding
rate to combat the nitrogen retention
which hurt our nitrogen supply factor
here so if we can manage our fall soil
nitrogen to have low soil nitrogen in
the fall so avoid fall manure
applications avoid excessive tillage and
the fall which can stimulate
mineralization we could get away with
the lower non legging seeding rate which
would help maintain high nitrogen supply
the other thing we saw is that sites
that had high soil carbon levels or high
soil organic matter levels there's
nitrogen coupled with that carbon and
that increased our nitrogen supply so
building high soil organic matter levels
can help offset some of the negative
aspects of higher nam legumes seeding
rates the other great indirect effect of
increased soil carbon that we saw is
that it helped to maintain lower c2n
ratios in our cover crop tissue in the
fall in the spring because there's more
nitrogen available in the soil from
mineralization and whatnot so all of
these effects interacting with each
other are kind of difficult to keep
track of so we developed a little online
calculator that takes all this
information it gives you a little
graphical output and helps you make a
decision about what type of nan legging
seeding rate to use what type of
nitrogen supply you'll get for your next
corn crop and this is described in a
paper that we have publishing actually
download just the HTML file everything
is embedded in that single file can
download that and and use the calculator
and we're working on getting some
tutorial videos
post it on on how to do that but it's an
attachment to this paper a supplement to
this paper you can download it now or
you can contact me for the file if
you're interested so conclusions
mixtures can increase multi
functionality but it requires intensive
management so functional diversity was
more important than species diversity
and our data shows that you should
target functional evenness and
divergence biomass evenness is a
challenge to achieve so you need to
select species with compatible growth
rates and adjust your seeding rates to
the climate and so on that nitrogen
status of your site and then services
are bundled and have trade-offs so to
minimize that nitrogen supply and
retention trade-off it's actually about
how you manage your soils so that was
kind of an interesting outcome from that
so I think that's all thank you I have
time for questions or okay a question or
two yes ma'am
after all
so that really varied depending on the
year and depending on the site so so
yeah that varied we took that we took
that into account by the c2n ratio so
that's essentially going to be a moving
target and in this calculator here we
actually have there's variables for your
spring growing degree days and your fall
growing degree days and those actually
shift the C to end ratio behind the
scenes in the model and so that can help
you account for some of that as well
yes
hmmm I think that there's still
something to the insurance effect of
having because yeah they may not Mike
some species might do better or worse I
guess I wonder if they really do have
the same functional traits are they
really are they going to be impacted
negatively by the same environmental
extremes that might happen I guess I
think in terms of the insurance
hypothesis I would say if you're
thinking about your traits around the
edge try and populate more traits around
the edge so that if you lose a few your
you still have others around the edges I
wouldn't necessarily try and pile up
multiple species on three points of a
triangle does that make sense yep yes
yeah so I think all of the seed
companies are good and they know their
products better than anyone else does
and I think that as a community we're
all learning together and I guess what I
would hope is that some of this
information can ultimately get you know
integrated into how companies are making
their mixes I think the challenge though
is that what we're seeing is that the
same ratio of seeding rates may not be
appropriate for every farm I think
that's going to be a challenge for the
seed companies because they need to mix
their seed and bulk to some extent and
have a consistent lineup and so I think
some of the farm tuning may have to
occur at the farm level the farmer may
have to say okay I'm going to procure
this stream of seed and then I'm going
to decide what my mixing ratio is going
to be so but so that adds a little bit
of extra management challenge to the
farmer alright well I probably used up
my time so all right thank you this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell edu